the Treasury Department's internal
watchdog is investigating the release of
Michael Cohen's banking records
president Trump's longtime attorney
received millions of dollars from
companies seeking access to the
president after the election
Michael avenatti the lawyer for adult
film actress stormy Daniels revealed
Cohen's banking information Cohen's
lawyers call much of the information
completely inaccurate CBS News has
reviewed financial documents that appear
to support a vanadis story Julianna
Goldman is at the White House Juliana
good morning good morning the treasure
is IG is independent of the agency's
political appointees now the revelations
also provide new details into the
special counsels investigation and show
how Michael Cohen who did not get a job
in the Trump administration with trying
to keep a foot in the door that's the
decision of an independent company and
has nothing to do with the White House
the White House tried to distance itself
from the latest chapter in the unfolding
saga surrounding Michael Cohen who in
late 2017 was apparently marketing
himself as a conduit into the new
administration a source at Novartis
tells CBS News Cohen approached the
company 18 months ago promising that he
could advise it on how to get access to
mr. Trump's team Novartis said it paid
essential consultants the company Cohen
set up in the fall of 2016 they only met
with him once but still paid Cohen close
to 1 million dollars because they were
under contract
he was also paid by AT&T and Korea
aerospace all three major corporations
with business before the government in
an email to employees AT&T said the
company hired several consultants to
quote understand how the president and
his administration might approach a wide
range of policy issues both AT&T and
Novartis said they spoke with Special
Counsel Robert Muller last November was
it hush money to stay silent
yes Cohan used essential consultants to
pay stormy Daniels to keep quiet about
her alleged affair with mr. Trump the
special counsel has passed the case to
the US attorney in New York
Daniel's attorney Michael avenatti they
should release the bank statements
associated with this count for the
public to see if there's nothing to hide
they show tonight it
this also reveals a whole dimension of
Washington's influence game that has
continued under this administration
you know shortly after the election and
after mr. Trump won major corporations
were scrambling to try and make inroads
into the new administration and Gail
very few people could market themselves
as knowing the ins and outs of mr.
Trump's orbit Michael Cohen was one of
them all right Giuliana thank you very
much